in this video I want to talk about
gluconeogenesis gluconeogenesis is sort
of like the reverse pathway of
glycolysis gluconeogenesis comes from
gluco meaning glucose neo meaning new
and Genesis meaning to make or create so
we're synthesizing glucose from pyruvate
which is essentially sort of the
reversal of glycolysis but it's not the
exact reversal hypothesis the reason why
is because excuse me there were three
irreversible steps right in glycolysis
the three irreversible glycolytic steps
from glycolysis they can't they're not
really irreversible what that means is
irreversible is that they're that step
can't be reversed by that particular
enzyme it needs a different enzyme so
the three irreversible glycolytic steps
need different they need different
enzymes to be reversed okay so how many
steps then is gluconeogenesis glycolysis
was ten steps gluconeogenesis is
actually eleven steps now why is that
the reason why is because the pyruvate
kinase step from glycolysis needs to be
reversed it needs two steps to be
reversed so all of the steps from
glycolysis can be reversed in one step
except the pyruvate kinase step it needs
two steps so that extra step is the
reason why gluconeogenesis is eleven
steps long and eleven reactions long
instead of just ten now let's get into
these these are these enzymes so in
glycolysis the first step was taking
glucose and turning it into glucose
6-phosphate
this would be the if going backwards
going from glucose 6-phosphate to alpha
D glucose this would be the last step in
will go neo Genesis and this is actually
catalyzed by glucose 6-phosphate fossa
taste and the reason why is because
phosphatase is if you recall they are
enzyme that hydrolyzed
phosphate groups off of molecules so
here we're going over losing this this
this phosphate group here
we're inputting a water we're inputting
water and we're losing that phosphate
group now this reaction actually occurs
in the endoplasmic reticulum of the
liver the endoplasmic reticulum which I
will abbreviate as ER of the liver so
this would be of course the the last
step of gluconeogenesis excuse me sorry
about that
now fructose 1 6 bisphosphate was the
committed molecule to by kala sis now if
that step is going to be reversed it
definitely can't be reversed by the
phospholipid kinase that created it so
we're going to go back to fructose
6-phosphate by getting rid of this
phosphate group here we're very much in
the same way that we did up here with
this glucose-6-phosphatase this thing
though it's not I think I'd look with 6
phosphate instead it's acting on
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate so it's going
to be called fructose 1 6 bisphosphate
ace so it's going to again hydrolyze one
of those phosphate groups off and
results in 406 phosphate so recall the
reversal of this ups this step up here
was the XO kinase step here
um if we were the glycolytic step would
be going from fructose 6-phosphate for
just 1 6 bisphosphate and that's
catalyzed by fructose photo should be
phosphofructokinase 1 but in this case
we have for just 1 6 bisphosphate ace
catalyzing this disk look
gluconeogenesis Thep so that's it for
for that one in terms of that that we're
reversing that reaction now this here at
the end here are the other two steps so
now I mentioned that the pyruvate kinase
step needs 2 steps to be reversed
so going from phosphoenolpyruvate 2 to
pyruvate was 1 step in glycolysis but
now in order to get from pyruvate back
over to phosphoenolpyruvate we have to
do it in two steps and the reason why
was because the pyruvate kinase step was
highly exergonic it was very spontaneous
it released a lot of energy so in order
to reverse that we're actually going to
have to input some energy and actually
go through two steps so this first step
here going from pyruvate this three
carbon molecule were going to turn it
into oxaloacetate and notice this is a
new molecule we haven't seen this
molecule just yet so notice the
difference between these these two
carboxyl groups are the same up here
these two ketone groups is the same this
methyl group here is the ch2 group here
but notice the difference is that we
added this carboxyl group here so this
enzyme is actually called pyruvate
carboxylase and this of course would be
the first step of gluconeogenesis
so it's pyruvate carboxylase so we're
adding a carboxyl group to pyruvate
again the enzyme name makes sense so we
have to include this here we're adding
we're adding a carboxyl group we're
actually adding it as a carbon dioxide
and if you know this carbon dioxide is a
gas and typically in order to Det
in order to insert a gas into a reaction
it's not them like the easiest thing to
do and this is definitely an end
process and we're going to use a form of
energy if you recall ATP is the energy
currency in our cell and that's exactly
what we're going to use to drive forward
this reaction here so we're going to
invest in ATP and what's going to end up
happening is going to hydrolyze that so
as to power this reaction we haven't
that turned into an adp and that
phosphate group doesn't actually get too
attached to the oxaloacetate so ends up
just being here freed up that's
essentially what happens here so
actually one more thing I forgot to
mention about this enzyme up here is
that this occurs this enzyme it is in
the cytosol of cells but pyruvate
carboxylase this reaction occurs in the
mitochondrial matrix mitochondrial
matrix of the cell okay so pyruvate
carboxylase occurs in the mitochondrial
matrix whereas the rest of the steps
occur in the cytosol now let's was again
just to recall we added this carboxyl
group hence the carboxylase we're adding
it to pyruvate and pyruvate carboxylase
and this enter this is going to require
energy to go back to oxaloacetate and it
makes sense here that we can actually
invest this energy because if we're
undergoing gluconeogenesis that means we
want to go we probably have enough
energy we don't want glycolysis to go
we don't want glycolysis and
gluconeogenesis both happening in the
same cell at the same time because
baikal assists makes energy by breaking
down glucose and gluconeogenesis stores
energy by creating glucose so we
definitely don't want both processes
happening at the same time but just sort
of as a heads up we only want
gluconeogenesis to happen when we want
to store energy and it would make sense
that we would have ATP around if we're
ready to store energy we want to store
energy when in high energy states if we
already have plenty of energy that's
when we store stuff store energy so in
this case we have ATP being used up
because it's already around there's
plenty of it around okay now
once we have this oxaloacetate here
we're entering that into
phosphoenolpyruvate
the enzyme that catalyzes that reaction
is phospho enol pyruvate carboxylase
let's see if we can make sense of this
enzyme named phosphoenolpyruvate
carboxykinase so I'm going to look for a
carboxyl group either coming or leaving
and I'm kinase I'm expecting the
addition of a phosphate and that's
exactly what we get here so notice that
between these two two molecules the
carboxyl group up here stays the same
the ch2 group here is the same but we
form as alkene and we add a phosphate
here right so we're inputting a
phosphate for sure somehow and it's from
a kinase we're also losing this carboxyl
group so we're gonna lose that carboxyl
group as a carbon dioxide but where did
this this phosphate come from well it's
a kinase now normally when we think
about kinase as we think about it adding
a phosphate from ATP but for whatever
reason in this case instead of an ATP
we're actually adding it from a gtp
so we run from a gtp to a GDP and the
phosphate from the gtp gets attached to
create phosphoenolpyruvate
and this of course occurs in the cytosol
I don't have room to ever at all squeeze
it in there this occurs in this cytosol
okay so that's essentially it in the
next video I'll talk about how some of
these enzymes are allosteric ly
regulated but that's essentially it
as far as gluconeogenesis goes every
other step in gluconeogenesis was
reversible from glycolysis so if you
were writing out that step you would
just have to make sure that you were
writing the arrow from one way together
so I'll actually show a quick example in
another video thanks for watching